una carrera contra el tiempo para ayudar
a los sobrevivientes en Siria alerta la
OMS tras el terremoto que sacudió tanto
al país de oriente medio como a Turquía
además de la destrucción masiva en
muchas zonas el acceso por carretera
está interrumpido dentro de Turquía y a
través de la frontera en el noroeste de
Siria la OMS reconoce la gran capacidad
de respuesta de Turquía y considera que
las principales necesidades no cubiertas
pueden estar en Siria corto y medio
plazo
sería que ya sufre una crisis
humanitaria desde hace años debido a la
guerra civil y a un brote de cólera
Ahora tiene un nuevo frente que preocupa
a la OMS
estamos especialmente preocupadas por
las zonas que aún no tenemos información
el mapeo de daños está en curso para
entender Dónde tenemos que centrar
nuestra atención
entre tanto la media luna roja dice
estar preparada para distribuir ayudas
en todas las regiones del país incluso a
las que están controladas por la
oposición
estamos dispuestos a enviar un convoy de
ayuda a través de la línea transversal a
las zonas afecta en la región de itlip
en el norte de Siria si ellos nos abren
una carretera iremos no tenemos ningún
problema con ello
Alemania por su parte a través de su
ministra de exteriores analena baerbug
pidió a Rusia que ayude a presionar a
Siria para que permita la entrada de
suministros
todos los actores internacionales
incluida Rusia deben utilizar su
influencia sobre el régimen sirio para
garantizar que la ayuda humanitaria para
las víctimas llegue realmente allí y que
no se pongan más obstáculos porque cada
minuto cada hora cuenta aquí para que
más víctimas puedan ser rescatadas o
salvadas
dan anunció el envío de ayudas para
socorrer a las víctimas del terremoto